bye everyone which are Ilana's on and
today i am at coco supernova plus
playing spider-man
except that I'm calling it
[Music]
trait aside from obviously post playing
and dressing up again isn't that much to
do
so I should mention that I'm actually
wearing my orange dance costumes was not
my poster why leave a link below to
dance boss webpage because he is easily
one of the best really male cosplaying
he is amazing thank you Dan
[Music]
[Music]
but hey I also give up due to the time
recording several without a new job that
I cover you told you guys bouncer
like two or three years now on the radio
Triple J sort of resident came on so I'm
covering supernova for the
exciting
like Rihanna
it is a really
but I was at the trade show I thought
that I would show you guys the steps
that I saw many Ounces become there's
gonna water
no one it's volume 3 of saga which is
pretty much one of my favorite book
series
it's busy on
nightmare Batman
real time since I start my man statue
that I was like holy crap my t-zone and
this one is just amazing
[Music]
so I guess I mostly am a spiky today
because Dan
and the costumes really really good
quality is like always to not just like
something that in super comfy so in
general
also kind of still really full of life
is an exhausting
oh yeah
[Music]
so we just left the convention it was a
pretty good day the people kind of be
beside of me because I'm trying to walk
back to the hotel and we have to go get
a tripod for tomorrow so I'm pretty much
just gonna have to wear this Spidey suit
for a lot longer which is great and
today is the beginning of supernova t3
where I'm getting to interview some
really awesome people so I guess that's
the end of this video but I will have
the entities uploaded on my channel
across the next few weeks so I'll see
you guys then my